the human genome the blueprint of our
species a three billion letter long
genetic code with all the instructions
to make you or me or is it the official
sequence published in 2001 is the Human
Genome Project was largely based on a
man of white European descent known only
as rp11 who lived in Buffalo New York
it's a bias that matters because we're
now entering a new era of genetic
medicine and people of different
ancestries could miss out
99.9 percent of the human genome is
identical across the population it binds
us together as a species but the other
0.1 percent contains variations in the
genetic code that reflect our ancestry
now in a major undertaking scientists
have published the first pan genome it's
a genetic manual based not on just one
person but on 47 individuals of
different Heritage a first step to
reflecting diversity across the
population it includes 109 19 million
new variations in the genetic code and
more than 1100 repeated sections of DNA
that contain genes in effect they're
like slightly different translations of
a book that's been written in another
language as scientists say a better
understanding of more diverse DNA code
should stop some groups missing out on
genetic advances could be that somebody
is sick and we will be blind to the DNA
difference that is making them sick or
it could be because I believe that
genomics become relevant even for people
and as part of their routine Medical
Care to keep them healthy that we will
be blind to a DNA difference that they
have that might put them at risk for a
certain condition take one example the
gene for lipoprotein a a fatty molecule
in the blood variations in that Gene are
responsible for the biggest genetic risk
for heart disease in African Americans
but only as a result of the pan genome
has that risk been understood and it
could lead to treatments that Target the
Gene and are more clinically effective
two decades on from the first sequence
of the human genome the book of life has
been given a long overdue rewrite so we
can all benefit from the revolution in
genetic medicine